legendary former notre dame women's
basketball coach that's muffet mcgraw
is taking a stand against the
disparities between men and women sports
she says this generation of female
athletes expects more and quote
we won't stop until we get it mcgraw
spent 33 years coaching notre dame
notre dame leading them to two national
championships and nine
final four appearances you go muffet
mcgraw
joins us this morning to discuss good to
see you coach mcgriff to say the blatant
disrespect shown to the women was just
jaw dropping to me and thank you to
sedona prince for pointing it out to all
of us
but i've heard you say you weren't
surprised i looked at that video and i
thought
who is in the room making these
decisions why weren't you surprised
i think we've been fighting this battle
for years and years probably decades i
think that
similar to what most women across the
country whatever field you're in
has gone through and that is we're
treated with
the kind of feeling that we're just not
enough that we're somehow
less than and they think it's okay
and that is probably the biggest problem
that they think it's okay
yeah you in your statement your
statement's great by the way you said
it's like women are treated like the jv
team to the men's
to the men's team and that is not okay
that's exactly right and if you look at
the games just turn on the games
you'll see the women's court we're all
playing on college campuses but the men
have been provided with a brand new ncaa
court with march madness the huge logo
in the middle
where on the women's court you're going
to still see two lines for the men's
line and the women's line for
three-point shots
there's a volleyball court on one of the
courts the con
the conference logo or the college logo
is still on the court it doesn't even
look like an ncaa game
yeah so coach mcgraw you say you've been
fighting this fight for decades now and
yet we're still having these issues so
what would you say needs to happen right
now to make sure the next march madness
gets off to a better start well we've
never had a woman leading the ncaa maybe
that's a good place to start but
honestly i think that one of the things
we can do right away
is to call the tournaments the men's
basketball tournament and the women's
basketball tournament
when you turn on the tv and you look at
the guide it just says
ncaa basketball tournament and of course
that just means men's
the ncaa runs two social media accounts
one called march madness one called the
final four
and of course they're both men's they
don't state that
and i think that would be a start to say
men's basketball and women's basketball
coach i was struck by the statistic that
um among
among the power five the 65 schools in
the power five conferences
that of the six of the athletic
directors are only four women
and do we need more women in the room
making decisions here
i'm glad that you were shocked by that i
think that that is so important that we
hire more women
and i think that's the trend nationally
right now i think people are looking
corporations are looking
to promote and hire more women so that
we have a more diverse workforce
and that is something i think we need in
athletics it has been a male-dominated
institution for so long and i think it's
time that we evened out the score we
have
many women playing 109 has been a great
thing we went from 200 000 women to 2
million women playing sports
and now we need to have that reflected
in the upper levels but coach the number
of women
coaching women's basketball teams is
actually declining and significantly
why is that happening you know i think
there's a lot of reasons for that i
think work-life balance as in most
professions across the country that is
an issue
especially now during the pandemic when
women are taking the brunt of it
you're trying to coach it's not
something you can do virtually you're
there in person
and if you have a family at home you're
torn between what you can do with trying
to get them homeschooled and work on
what they have to do
so i think it's important that we make
rules and legislate rules in our game
that allow women to do that but i think
right now it's mostly opportunity
i don't think the ads are hiring enough
women and i think it's because most of
the ads are men as you said
and they hire people who look like them
i would like to know what you thought
coach when you looked at that video did
you call anybody and are you optimistic
that things will change
what do you think you know i i just
thought
again it's the same thing i'm just so
tired of it i think that is my biggest
issue i've been fighting this for so
long but i'm just so happy with this
generation because they're looking at
this and saying
that is not going to happen with this
group and i love that
yeah they really are like enough we will
not accept that and they're not
look how quickly it changed over the
weekend it changed and perhaps
ncaa president muffet mcgraw
there you go tony muffet mcgraw
melvin mcgraw what's the name on your
birth certificate i'm just curious
i i don't recall i'm not at that age
where i have a short-term memory
[Laughter]
thank you very much we appreciate it